this shows so [ __ ] good now normally
I try not to do too many installments of
why it's awesome you know in two shorter
time span I try and only do one a month
but having now binge my way through the
second season of the good place because
it came out on Netflix in anticipation
of the third season which is gonna start
hammering very soon on the 27th I
believe um if I'm gonna talk about why I
love this show this is kind of the ideal
time to do it cuz I'm caught up and it's
about to do the new season so let's talk
about it I'm gonna go spoil it free for
as long as I can cuz I'm finding like
not as many people seem to had seem to
know or have heard of the show as I
would have thought I mean I don't know
what the ratings are cuz I don't follow
ratings like on anything because I as
long as it has rating sufficient to get
it renewed that's literally the only
thing I care about so I don't know how
well watch the show actually is but I
love it so let's start with premise when
the show opens episode 1 season 1 we
meet Eleanor Eleanor played by Kristen
Bell is a woman who has died and she has
arrived in the afterlife
she has arrived in one of two places
where she could possibly go there is the
good place and there is the bad place
and Eleanor is one of the lucky few who
made it to the good place and I do mean
whew there is a very high bar that is
set to be able to get into the good
place what she swiftly realizes and what
is revealed to the audience soon I don't
know about halfway ish into the first
episode is that uh there's been a
mistake she's not supposed to be in the
good place she was kind of a terrible
human being and that's your starting
premise and he goes from there and we
meet the other characters well there's
Michael played by Ted Danson who he runs
the neighborhood now what the
neighborhood is is they base
we have collections of I don't know
think of a number but they have a
collection of so many humans who
qualified for the good place and an
architect which is what Michael is
creates a neighborhood for them that is
to be their ideal everyone gets a house
that is meant to their own preferences
and ideal situations and you know what
is available to them there is a sort of
a an AI for lack of a better term called
Janet you say hey you say Janet and she
just shows up and she can get and do an
answer almost anything and so there's
that day about at their disposal
so there's Janet as well who I love
possibly my favorite character and then
we also have some of the other residents
of the neighborhood that we get focused
on there's Chiti who is identified as
Eleanor's soul mate now who she D he is
he was an ethics professor and Eleanor
confides in him pretty quickly that
she's not supposed to be there which
sends him into an into a complete moral
quandary like oh my god now what do I do
you know cuz he's the guy any kind of
guy who's going to literally drive
himself crazy by going well
should I tell Michael that there's
someone who isn't supposed to be here
because that would be the honest thing
and telling the truth is important but
then I am condemning this person to the
bad place and that is does that make it
a malicious Act should I now not do it
like he'll drive himself nuts with this
so that's Cheney and and while he is
introduced as Eleanor's soul mate you
know obviously Eleanor's not who she's
supposed to be so they don't get along
the way that there's supposed to do and
there's another a couple of soul mates
who we also get on an emphasis on there
is tani who was philanthropy
philanthropist she was real big on you
know raising money for charity and she's
she's a bit of a name-dropper she was a
HobNob with celebrities and whatnot but
she did a lot of good stuff and her soul
mate is John Yoo who is a monk with
of silence now I am gonna get to a
little bit more detail on some of the
things that happen to these characters
when I start talking about what I really
like about them but some of that is
considered spoilers so if you've never
seen the show at all this is the point
at which I would say I really love it I
love the actors are all great it's
incredibly clever the way it progresses
it does have a continually progressive
story it doesn't reset to 0 at the end
of every episode so it is it continuing
narrative and it pulls that off while
remaining funny and clever and true to
its characters from start to finish as
far as I've gotten into it the complete
first two seasons so that is my
recommendation for you to go and watch
it now if you feel like you need a
little bit more of a nudge I'm gonna
start talking about some of the
character developments and things that
we find out into the first season when I
get to like the legitimate spoilers of
stuff that happens later I'll give you
another warning because that'll be your
final one so coming back to John you it
might seem weird that like there's a
focus on just the silent monk what is
there to do with this guy well John you
is like Eleanor is also not who he
appears to be he there was there was a
mix-up with him as well and he is not a
Buddhist monk he is a Floridian [ __ ]
named Jason and Jason God Jason is
amazing Jason is a level of stupid that
I had it took me a little while to warm
to him I had a hard time buying him
because he is so dumb like it is
incredible how stupid he is I mean he
was smart enough to realize that if he
held up the vow of silence
you know facade that he wouldn't have to
he wouldn't get in trouble and he
wouldn't have to answer questions and
admit that he has no idea what's going
on and so he knew I have to do that but
that's about it that's about the limits
of his intelligence and sort of what's
amazing about Jason is it's really hard
to make a character that stupid and who
is frequently very annoying to the other
characters in
because generally when you make a
character who by design is annoying to
the other characters in your story they
tend to also be annoying to the audience
see jar jar binks as a there's a pretty
solid example of that so what works
about Jason is that he does actually
have a good heart
he's usually too dumb to think through
the consequences of anything he does
both in terms of what it'll mean to him
and its possible impact on anybody else
like he's the kind of guy who would get
in in his head oh I want to go to this
club I hear I don't have a car and he
would Hotwire somebody's car to drive
they're not thinking oh you don't ask
I'll steal your car just like oh you
know it's just sitting there I'll take
it this is great
like not with malice but just like a
complete disregard for the impact of
anything he ever does or says or thinks
he is he is an adorable dumbass and it's
it is I'm surprised that I've taken a
shine to him the way that I have and as
far as some of the other characters go I
for me Ted Danson is he was my initial
sort of interest point because I love
Ted kids and I loved Cheers
ten Danson is a great inherent likable
likeability to him and actually the part
of Michael was really difficult was what
Michael is especially in the first
season he's an exposition machine he's
there to tell Eleanor and you know by
extension to the audience what's going
on how stuff works yeah if he's eat he's
honestly even more of an exposition
machine the Janet who is a literal
exposition machine and it's really hard
to take a character whose purpose is to
just dump information and make them
somebody you like to watch cuz generally
you're like oh look just get through the
explanation okay so we can move things
forward but he's he makes it enjoyable
it's a skill that he has it's a skill
that anthony Stewart head has Giles on
Buffy the Vampire Slayer hat some people
can do it but it's really hard it's
really hard to just be the guy with all
the answers and have that be somebody
who you enjoy so he's great at that
Kristen Bell I do have a soft spot for
Kristen but I actually haven't seen her
in a ton of live-action stuff to be
honest but I enjoyed this because
Kristen Bell has a you know as a
performer has a bubbliness to her has
you know just sort of a friendliness in
a way inherently like as a person I get
that vibe off her so to see her play
somebody so unapologetically awful like
unlike say Jason who does not have any
appreciation for what anything he does
means Eleanor makes deliberate choices
that hurt people knowing it's gonna hurt
other people and she doesn't care or
maybe even finds it funny so she is a
horrible human being and again it's
really impressive that they take someone
that despicable because she is she
really is and make them someone you root
for make them somebody that you care
about
honestly all these characters are
characters that feel like it feels like
almost a cast that was come up out in a
writing exercise of here are the
templates of characters that almost
never work do a story with nothing but
that so you have the horrible person
that you are expected to sympathize with
the exposition machine who is still fun
to be around the dumbass who's not
annoying to the audience the indecisive
character that as an audience member you
enjoy his indecisiveness but you and it
doesn't make you want to strangle him
you know the the the stuck-up character
who you still kind of can't help but be
like I you're fun to be there but your
character template is also kind of awful
but I know stay do more stuff taking
these characters that should be annoying
that should be irritating that would be
a drag on almost any other show
populating the show with all with almost
nothing but them and making it work and
making us like them all of them that's
astounding to be completely honest and
now I need to
to some drill proper spoilers that are
more than just a couple of episodes into
the show so if this is your last warning
for like major spoilers okay
so end a season won't we find out that
really in the bad place which
unfortunately did have spoiled for me
and I had as well for me in a similar
way to how the red wedding was blow for
me for Game of Thrones which was that I
saw like a sketch in this case it was
like a cartoon that made reference to
that because that was how the red
wedding us well do me for me when South
Park did its Game of Thrones spoof and I
hadn't been watching the show yet so and
that this was spoiled for me in a
similar manner but it still works it's a
great reveal and it's a great turn for
Michael and it gives Ted days at the
reveal that yet he's the architect of
this neighborhood but he's he designed
it to torture these people not just
torture these people but get them to
torture each other because Pellinore
compose throws cheating into complete
existential horror because she keeps
forcing him into it into these moral and
ethical quandaries and he feels
constantly awful and Eleanor is
surrounded by people who are literally
better than her and her entire life was
spent on do you know thundering the idea
you're not better than me and you know
to honey just keep getting one up too by
the way things things are never quite
getting satisfaction and then she gets
paired with Jason who's just such a
freakin [ __ ]
and just the the way they interact in
the way they drive each other crazy and
Eleanor having that realization of Oh
Michael and realizing what he is and Ted
Danson has this awesome turn that starts
with just this laughs this is great oh
my god and then watching him shift and
getting to know basically demon Michael
is so much fun especially because
personality-wise
he doesn't really change what he's after
changes and you know he it what came off
initially his affection for these people
it shifts to contempt but his gentle
persona doesn't change he's the same guy
in terms of personality you just
a different angle on it go oh that's
what was going on
now after that reveal I really wondered
how season 2 could pick up from that and
it picks up from it brilliantly it
starts in a way that you're like oh
they're basically gonna retread the
first season because the way season 2
starts is that Michael after they
realized that the end of season 1 was
going out and Michael wipe their
memories like fine we're gonna start
again I'm gonna make some adjustments
we're gonna get this right and then the
first two episodes of season 2 you
realize he has to keep her starting them
over and over and over and over again
because they keep figuring it out and he
comes to a realization that no matter
how many times he resets them they are
actually becoming better people through
their interactions with each other
through what they draw from each other
and that puts Michael in a different
headspace because that's not supposed to
happen the way the system is supposed to
work is where you go good plays are bad
places determined by your actions on
earth and that's all that determines it
nothing that you do after you die no
matter where you end up nothing you do
after that impacts anything because the
belief is that you when you die you are
who you were you can't keep changing you
can't evolve further but he's watching
these people and going they're changing
and they're getting better something's
weird here and he basically kind of
switches sides partly selfishly because
if his boss realizes how many times he's
reset this when he only got a clearance
to reset it once he's actually gonna be
a massive trouble and get yeah I mean
effectively killed and so he's got a
selfish motivation initially but you see
him evolve a genuine sense of emotion
you see him become basically more human
and he hates it so much of the time
which is wonderful to see and there is
such a cavalcade of amazing guests
characters as well I even though it's
the same actress who plays Janet I
really like bad Janet um the the bad
plays version of Janet which is redic I
actually like a lot of the bad place
figures Trevor
who didn't come back in season two
unfortunate I do hope we see him again
but Trevor's the worst and actually
there's so many characters who are the
worst Elinor's the worst tejani is the
worst
Trevor's the worst but they're all
distinctly different flavors of the
worst which I love that I'm actually I'm
finding myself I'm really gravitating
towards characters who are the worst and
who the audience are not like oh but
they're really okay no no these people
are terrible it's okay to have fun with
them but they're terrible let's be
honest I I kind of I'm finding myself
enjoying that not always but more often
than I would have thought so Trevor I
like a lot
derek is amazing in season two when
Janet creates a boyfriend named Eric who
is just wow I don't even know how to
describe Derrick I can tell you though
he has possibly my favorite line in the
whole show maximum Derrick it's Oh God
I could just keep going on and on it and
the intelligence of this show as it
talks about real philosophical concepts
and moral quandary that have been
debated by philosophers and academics
for centuries are all in here including
named drops for a lot of these these
guys and where these concepts come from
it's really cool how intelligently
researched this is but also the ways
continue to progress what they've set up
for for season three is gonna demand a
completely different show than we got in
season two which already demanded a
pretty notably different show than we
had in season one this show is literally
reinventing itself every single season
what it's doing from the ground up is a
wholly different thing in the way it
goes about it and shifts across the
season you're like it can't go back to
what it was and that's exciting and it
makes me both very excited and very
nervous about the next season I think
that Michael Schur who created this show
I seems to me like he has a very sound
idea for what he's doing going into
season three
that I'm going to be nervous because I
think trying to figure out new places to
go after where it looks like they're
going for season 3
basically having returned to these
people back to life like undone their
deaths and giving them more time on
earth to see if the evolution that they
went through and the afterlife does
still happen if they're on earth you
know basically confirming did they only
get better because of circumstances that
they would never be in on earth or are
they capable of actually becoming better
people on their own and you know so
that's that's a whole new set up and it
it has a lot of potential but I don't
know how you shake things up again after
two major shakeups and I worry that
going like if it gets a season four
going to a fourth season that it's gonna
be you know we're gonna be expecting the
shake-up
so that's the first thing but then if
you don't do it does the show become
stale and I I get nervous because
oftentimes these high concept shows have
you know several seasons worth of ideas
but then if they keep getting renewed
past the initial core ideas that's when
things get repetitive or go off the
rails or get weird but I'm very hopeful
for season three and the first two
seasons of this as far as I'm concerned
our gold so like I truly I have no
complaints I haven't I
this guy has no complaints about this
show like not not even like I would do
with when I did my white Gotham is
awesome going yeah first season a little
wonky no it was great it was great
immediately it stayed great through the
whole season stayed great through the
second season I I'm the guy who finds
problem with everything
I always very least one tiny thing and I
know I got nothing I love this show it's
wonderful and I
hope that you are watching it if you're
still watching this because I've done
massive spoilers in the first two
seasons so if you stick around you were
warned not my fault so that I'll wrap it
up there the good place first two
seasons what do you think about it
whatever you think drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
there's a whole bunch of stuff to do
there are buttons and there are links
and there are things for you to check
out including a link to the patreon so
check them out if you want and remember
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]